Hey hi mekka hiney ho that's always on
here system she um okay so for every one
that keeps bitching we just did pixels
listen I gotta go and for anyone that
keeps bitching it's like oh this kill
video ties this gap I don't like that
you did not live through Captain end the
game is not only where like does this
have like so little to do with the video
games that we grew up with but we were
excited to see the show we were just
wear what Mega Man and Kid Icarus I what
we're gonna do today
ah that's what you're man nothing else
that's that Simon Belmont no not as it
comes but we just had that was like the
plans but watch out the horrors um it
what a show it's out alone this could
get away with it because everything is
to be exact
nobody's ever they will ah but again for
his own thing see this like when people
ask us what's nostalgic to us they
realize we got a lot of Millennials and
younger people watching the show this is
our childhood I remember yes and I under
it out I get excited to see you know
it's Mario gonna pop up in this one and
that is kind of the biggest
disappointing thing is that like for a
show it's believed all the way to
Nintendo games like we saw so few of
them like the big thing was they did a
crossover with Link and Zelda and it's
like should we be like crossing paths
all bataki oh no we were just waiting
for the Mario and Zelda episodes because
the other ones like didn't make it to
fucking Simon Belmont that still pisses
me off to this day Simon Belmont is a
great character and I don't know who
decided to give him goggles and put him
in a Launchpad McQuack jacket although
there's a good silver burgos years later
I do can say no it's so cuz they're
obviously like they're doing almost like
a gay stereotype of the 80s I think
myself it's like you know oh you mean
this guy you know from this game would
long hair wears leather carries a whip
and has a short skirt you know this is
during the phone
oh yeah I'm wondering if it was
something where they're just like well
we can't draw him like he should look
like because then people will think
they're watching Masters of the Universe
asus leather skirts bare chested whip
yeah so maybe that was just made up
maybe just saw you looking the picture
it's like and they were just doing a
joke oh I wonder with like they looked
at Simon's quest you know Kells me into
each other or this guy sounds like oh
hello I'm gonna rip you and I way let's
just make that the character like almost
and it just killed gay or not I can't
see him sounding the original one
sounding no no no no I mean but like I
said I think that was like like I would
imagine he would sound more like he-man
I had nothing not the fabulous secret
powers one I think he would have liked a
cool badass voice again like yeah stuff
like good I don't side by god you know
but cuz you can't so being you with like
a badass that was my series I loved
those games on the NES and super
Castlevania for one the best Super
Nintendo games yeah still amazing still
holds up oh it still holds up
Castlevania freeze still difficult as
fuck oh let's do a game yeah - I hate I
can't stand it - well that was the whole
Nintendo sequel curse where every the
medians racing I'd be told it's
completely different you had Zelda -
Mario - Castlevania - we're all weird
they're also insanely long yeah superb
well Super Mario Brothers - was that
long but Zelda - shit yeah um I like
Zelda - though I say I got it those bad
I'm just probably talking about the show
yeah I like Selma to the show - uh I
will say this in the opening four years
when the kid gets sucked into the TV and
you see that green thing comes to the TV
going wow like that I never knew what
that was I always thought like some guys
running out - I told you to clean your
room yeah where where the hell's the
mother in all this shit's just like oh
my god where'd he go which is there's my
son's been abducted oh well um but yeah
only years later did I realize like oh
that techniques like for the TV I never
knew what the
yeah why cuz he doesn't look like that
throughout the rest of the show he looks
like a cartoon
why does Mega Man him that voice there's
just so doesn't look like Megan Mary but
knowing Doug again a Mega Man another
character I love they basically just
butchered most of the characters that
long no but again to be fair like even
the cover of the Mega Man games never
looks like Mega Man it's really making
the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
version of Legend of Zelda look pretty
solid we miss you per Mary Barra Super
Show yeah um but yeah princess what's
her face it should been like earthwork
Jim they just call it princess
what's-her-name
yeah what what game was she from again
they just made one up I like they just I
did they just made it up
I don't remember what game she was
supposed to be from they countered love
day you know just does my old uh or
could have been Princess Peach or
whatever but it was also that kind of
like 1998 of that sci-fi quality well
she was so dressed like the 80s like
big-time yeah well there's we forget
there was bleed over I've seen like
looking bad like when I'm from 1993 all
the way to about 93 the 80s were still
dying a very slowly yeah one Oh even the
early 80s you can see the sanity is
slowly dying and everything um but uh ya
know this was I don't know I don't hear
anyone giving like something about the
80s and like the 90s big lead early 90s
and stuff I think there's something it's
a little bit more forgivable I think not
just for our age but because it was just
so far removed and so goofy was almost
dominating it is amazingly comical that
you just had to laugh like it is just so
not representing this it's like the
Mario Brothers movie it's just like it's
a terrible representation of Mario and
in the the universe that Mario inhabits
and yet I still am fascinated by it cuz
I'm just like what were you smoking when
you came up with this like this weird
post-apocalyptic sci-fi universe you
know with the fungus everywhere in it
it's the same thing here it's just like
I I'm not gonna say it's good but it is
very weird like that there was kind of
like the 70s in the 80s like there was
kind of the psychedelic quality to
everything where it's like well we're
gonna do this I mean we're gonna change
everything and I was gonna have a sci-fi
band
and mother brain's gonna have this
critter see what may there's something
to I think like its back then there was
just this big thing like do not try
anything away from the formula or the
norm or anything so say well we gotta
make something out this you know video
game we gotta make a show out of it
so maybe it's like well Kate do it and
then just conform it to all these things
that we have tested and soft have work
really these more versus popular and
stuff like that trying to make it look
it's the only two video game ones that
stay true to their source of it gives me
a the Super Mario brother one like
because that whispers okay this can't
wait but always change every episode
what's like now they're doing a parody
Star Wars now they're doing a parody
Dracula now been doing a parody of Mad
Max like they always change it up and it
was Al's I don't know every time - no
the the later ones all agreeing for ya
memory of everyone's memory and um the
sonic Saturday morning I thought was
actually pretty I'm like okay like this
is adapted but this is actually pretty
dos - I would recognize this basically
as sonic just done really seriously um
so yeah those are the only two but
everything else was just off the fucking
walls like a dress I think it was just
the animators and the writers just
totally token up like in a closet
somewhere coming out with the munchies
be like alright let's do this either
we're gonna put out there but it's gotta
be fucking weird um I'm over there oh
he's gonna like chili dogs just like I
do
never oh so well I think I think - they
always say like comedy is tragedy plus
time and I think there is something to
be said about like just looking back
like when Batman Robin came out I was so
pissed off I was just so angry but now
that we've gotten the better Batman's
have come out all these different
versions it's like okay now I can look
back I can really have a plan we can
I can really have a good laugh at it um
you know so and I think doing that and
having that experience suddenly like
when I see science really bad I can sort
even though it's fun to get emotional
and passionate about it stuff like that
it's like I can take that step back it's
still no no this this is just a movie
and it's a representation of something
already silly
um system the video game worlds and the
plots in this show well a they didn't
make any sense but and I just I remember
watching as a kid and at some point I
felt like I was watching more out of
obligation because it was Nintendo yeah
land and I'm just like I'm like I'm not
sure I even like this but I feel like I
have to watch it yeah I got a support
Nintendo I just I got it I you know
Nintendo really didn't rule the world
like the wit Circassia showed but I am I
hung my how things have changed things
like Sony and Xbox and yeah so I don't
know I feel like once again like the
Super Mario this movie this could have
just written itself and yet it whatever
reason the made these weird changes I
mean all these weird changes in that oh
I love how there's a punch-out character
in there it would have been more funny
though he was like Isis Mike Tyson I
would have kill that they were placing a
bow with Mike Tyson I kept it in the
game if I can't even do it
why could can you do a Mike Tyson at the
top of the day yeah I just just showing
up like that and kicking it you know
kids I asked oh but no the grin I'm
gonna have to make orphans in a widow of
his wife or children but no what shocked
me is they okay you have Mother Brain
cool should be badass I'm like that's a
cool idea brain in a joke
you have the you have Metroid you have
Samus you have this yo sit that's really
you I'm a cool character since IKEA to
pick one of these characters to make a
character in the game
y'all ain't just this frantic the brain
is just so just enjoy because there's a
lot of potential for character there so
then they pick of it well what the fuck
do we do with this well it's copy for
kids it can't be too creepy so just
making my hilarious to listen to now I
mean though ya know show a show again um
but here's the thing you have Mother
Brain but no samus yeah what why why
could you get samus in them though maybe
maybe that is for the best well first of
all I guess after they butchered
everyone else know chances are they put
samus in the show and then they make it
a guy like not knowing is a woman like
oh shit we fucked this up make it
anything else about the characters right
oh that could that could have Anthony oh
yeah woman if you played the game but
then again I'm not convinced anybody
played the game yeah and you have to
play to the end anyway they're just like
oh whatever it's like they got nothing
else right they just fell into the game
said okay let's kind of do it like this
whatever so I bet you they did say it's
basically I mean carat doubts like every
character in world they basically read
page 1 of the instruction book and the
through bottom said fuck it
yeah just make shit out the watch meet
say yeah they were right we did it's
strangely mesmerizing the watch the the
enemy shit's not that great like one of
those things where it like it did not
age well so like the nostalgia
fabricated the day it came out the
nostalgia factor for me was great
watching it as an adult but objectively
speaking I'm like yeah this I remember
this being way better in my head and
even in my head I was like yeah I
remember oftentimes just watching and
going what the hell did they do with
these characters so well even the cut
the corporate shilling in it the one
word game boy enters the world oh my god
no with the talking game boy I mean that
it's bad that there's a talking game but
but they build up this will be all
greatest hero I think you will be this
phenomenal entity and they're just like
yeah game boy and so I'm like this is
like we because no one gives a shit
about the Power Pad
and even I have a longer poor power band
the corner there Hey look away I love
the here one shut up going but like you
I love the power pad women did that
never catch on
she was stupid it was fucking great
stupid we got a good workout with that
Tim you even read so fucking big Dylan
everybody you can use your hand now
that's Jimmy if we figure that out about
I know what two weeks after we yeah that
is catching no it would have been
funnier they're playing up is the big
hair it was virtual is a great years a
virtual boy you will save us oh you will
enjoy the many colors of red paint the
skies kittens in red um but yeah and
then even Winky boy shows up he doesn't
do anything and he's like a goof up and
stuff like that like he never redeems
the phones like why was this a great
hero they never explain it um if you
were born after 98 or something by the
way look up Virtual Boy and then just
have it on good fucking land I think
because it james rolfe and all the other
like it sort of it you know that's good
me because we must never forget never
forget no it was um what everyone said
in the shows door no I mind it said yeah
so I can strain my neck burn my retinas
and get a splitting headache
oh um but yeah that's uh how else can
you say I don't know I'm regretting
picking this one cuz I was like yeah it
really was a pretty shallow show I mean
it is stupid and it's it's fun in its
pure naivete and how it's trying to sell
its products it is very it is a time
capsule it's very much a product of its
time so yeah
you won't understand the fucked up world
where we came from it's got like
Nintendo's transformers this is clearly
just selling you you know these toys and
everything but it's with Nintendo so we
liked a little bit more but honestly the
fun dangerous for Christmas better care
oh yeah I not only that but looking back
honestly I could have used even more
selling I could use even more Nintendo
in it because everything looks so
different be like that's the thing about
the wizard the best parts of
that I loved as a kid were when they
were playing Super Mario Brothers yo
what's an actual house Nintendo if
you're gonna go yeah home corporate
sellout fine to give us the product to
sell our products I should say um so
yeah there it is uh pretty silly pretty
stupid but um it still makes me laugh I
I'd stolen what's a cat account gets
funny on it's funny so yeah that's about
it we'll see you at the next real
thoughts later put princess it's under
siege Oh